one thing i don't think we hear enough
is that after rosenbaum was shot
in
.739 of a second he got hit he was shot
at four times
richie mcginnis
did not run with the crowd he didn't
scream he didn't hit the ground why
he had no fear that kyle rittenhouse
would cause him any harm or i shouldn't
say that
his fear did not reach a level to where
he thought he should flee at all maybe
he was like there's some issue but i
genuinely believe richie ran up to
rosenbaum and acted like kyle wasn't
even there
because he knew in my opinion i haven't
talked to him about it he knew that kyle
wasn't a threat to him at all i think
that's the most important point the
second most important point in this
trial when they were watching a video
the judge walks over to the big screen
tv and sits down and watches the video
kyle rittenhouse walks up right behind
the judge and leans in right over his
left shoulder no bailiff no handcuffs no
complaints no one freaking out no one
was threatened by this kid not a single
person because they know he was only a
threat to those attacking him and lastly
all of you agree with me and i know it
if if ada bingo was on the ground in
kenosha during a riot and he saw kyle
rittenhouse he would run to him for
safety yes yep well let me tell you
something when i was there that night
right and i testified under oath so i
feel comfortable saying it again because
it's true
when i was there that night the first
time i saw kyle that night they were in
front of a
it was they call it car source 2 right
the second car dealership right
there were individuals on the roof they
had rifles on the roof right
and one of them was outside on the
ground as well and this was after the
rioters were going head-to-head with the
police and the police were pushing them
down sheridan pushing them they were
deploying rubber bullets they were
rioting they were taking concrete slabs
and destroying them on the floor and
throwing them at the cops taking
fireworks explosive devices throwing
them at the police vehicles um so as
they were getting pushed back when they
got to car source two these guys on the
you know on the building had their
rifles
um the rioters came to them they're like
you ain't the police you ain't the
police you ain't the cops you ain't like
getting super confrontational to the
point where the riders went behind car
source two grabbed more rocks more
concrete slabs and were throwing them at
the individuals with rifles on the top
of the building they brought a rock to a
gunfight okay
so the reason why this is important is
the first time i saw kyle was when he
came outside of this car source 2 and
attempted to de-escalate that situation
and you know what he had his hands like
he was you know he was going like kind
of like when you
uh when you're saying hey like calm down
calm down like like what instead of
saying the word calm down what do you do
you use your hands yeah that's what he
was doing and then the writers dispersed
because they were getting super
confrontational like you ain't the cops
you ain't the police you ain't the
police and then they dispersed so that's
the crazy thing
i've been to a bunch of events we had um
who was who tweeted today that white
supremacists in ferguson do you see that
i can't remember who it was no i don't
want to say the wrong person but you
know someone tweeted did you see that
drew no they were like when we were
marching in ferguson white supremacists
were hiding by the hill where michael
brown was shot and started they were
shooting at us and i'm like
you know i've been there and nothing
like that happened at least nobody said
it happened i didn't experience anything
like that no one i know said anything
like that but not a single activist
report anything like that until today
but the reason i bring that up is i'm on
the ground in ferguson
i watched the oath keepers i filmed the
oath keepers up on top of the building
standing there with weapons
then we had it was uh um
i can't remember the guy's name um
what's his name it's been a long time
the group comes down and they start
marching down
and it wasn't it wasn't stewart uh they
start walking down the road with rifles
and people are yelling at him just like
that you ain't the police you're not the
cops and the dude i can't remember his
name who's in the front he's like you
know a leader in the oath keepers he
goes we know we know we're just here for
everyone's safety and they were like
then why aren't you here protecting us
and he goes we are and they're like what
are you what and he's like yeah we want
to make sure the police don't hurt any
of you guys and they went oh what
we i was i watched him say he was like
he's like we're here like the cops
shouldn't hurt you guys you guys keep
protesting do your thing and we want to
make sure that everyone's safe and they
were like what
the thing about kenosha was it wasn't a
protest
at no point was it a protest i mean i
was in chicago
um
the night jacob blake got shot right and
i was looking on twitter and the first
thing i saw the literally one of the
first reports i saw
what was happening in kenosha was the
rioters were already taking brick took a
brick to a police officer's head knocked
him unconscious and then i started to
see other reports and i'm thinking to
myself
how far is kenosha
whoa it's like a what hour and a half
two two hour drive it was like a 300
uber right i don't even think that's i
think it's like an hour i don't remember
it was it was it was far and it was
during the lockdown in chicago at 11 p.m
at night i don't even know how i got an
uber
but i took it went there and right when
i showed up they already had dumpster
cars dumpster trucks on fire exploding
they were looting they were dumpster
carts like car trucks a dumpster rocks a
truck it's on my twitter anyone can go
watch it right now drew h live that's
one of the secrets
no full truck dumpster truck on fire and
uh the ones who brought rifles to the
kenosha riot first
was actually the rioters
i retweeted that today they they were
there night one and they were in a
standoff with the police in the middle
of the street and they had their rifles
they were the ones who brought guns
first that's a fact i watched that video
where it was like a mattress store or
something where i was being burned down
you see the smoke billowing out of the
building you see that video
i have to look at it because there's so
many burnt buildings and connections
right it's where the old guy is running
up and like trying to get people at his
store and then someone bashes him over
the back of that with a rock and he just
falls down he's lying on the ground
bleeding and they're all like laughing
and hooting at him i have to look at
that one but that night
was a mixture of arson
looting
vandalism
total violence they they burnt down
multiple buildings and that's why when
you hear the mainstream media this is
why they'll come out and say oh you're
just biased and they were chanting black
lives matter when they did it okay right
it's all on film and i posted it that's
not biased that's just the truth this is
i was in i was in san jose uh when
what it was it was that moment where the
guy got hit in the back of that with
rocks during the trump rally
and i tweeted out it was bernie sanders
supporters who did it there was a big
moment where they were like bernie
supporters bernie bros or violent bernie
supporters of violent bernie was like
you guys got to knock it off and i
tweeted like yeah those guys were bernie
supporters and they were like you're a
liar and you're far right and i was like
but that's what happened and they're
like how do you know they were bernie
supporters they were wearing bernie
shirts
like they were like wearing bernie a
couple of the people who were part of
the mob had bernie stickers and stuff on
them and they were screaming and shoving
people and i'm like that's just what i
don't know i didn't think it was that
big of a deal to be like oh yeah this
was the left that was engaging this
behavior at the time i genuinely thought
because i've seen the black bloc tactics
they're proud of the of what they call
the diversity of tactics i didn't
understand why they would all of a
sudden now deny the fact that they beat
people
all the time they were proud of it luke
i mean knows it luke was there when i
got attacked in new york yeah and luke
pulls a guy's mask off yeah well me and
my friends jumped he made sure that you
know we prevented further escalations
and and you know
you could just see a lot of these
actions unfold right before they unfold
with how people are preparing for it but
again when we look at what happened last
year during the summer we're talking
about over three
dozen people dying so people were
affected people did die people were hurt
people were injured but but and there
were several accounts of this but the
mainstream media picked this particular
case they highlighted it there's a lot
of tragedies out there there's a lot of
responsibility out there that you could
point to so many different people i
would directly point at big tech social
media i would directly point at the
mainstream media that was censoring any
opposing viewpoints promoting
obfuscating or even just sometimes
making excuses for for violence and i
think that was deliberate and i think
we're having that same kind of element
being brought back now it is during the
winter will we see large civil unrest we
don't know the national guard is being
deployed in wisconsin we have the nypd
chicago pd lapd seattle pd washington pd
all mobilizing yeah 500 national guards
all mobilizing their their police
officers because it's like
something i wonder why why are 500
national guard called out to kenosha
tonight if this whole thing started as a
peaceful protest why this is why i'm so
aggressive tim because they're trying to
lie they're trying to cover for these
violent criminals that literally showed
up to literally burn down buildings
threaten the community kenosha was
literally having a massive threat that
night and this is so underplayed because
they want to cover for these people and
make them look like little saints that
they're just uh opposing racism they
weren't what happened to kenosha had
nothing to do with jacob blake being
shot and you're biased for for talking
about what you saw and what you filmed
that we all plainly understood and i
want to stress a very important point
when they criticize your bias you
actually testified that you had concerns
about the guys with guns as well yeah
the the prosecutor was like you held up
your press badge when they were pointing
a laser pointer at you because you were
concerned for your safety and you were
like well i'm always concerned for my
safety but he was like but you're
worried they might have a gun on you yes
you said yes to that right this is why i
was trying to explain context in that
situation
that situation i just explained to you
where i saw kyle come out and attempt to
de-escalate a situation that was the
same building that the rioters were
taking rocks and throwing them at
individuals with rifles on top of the
building but but i listen i was sitting
there
filming it so the reason why i said of
course i'm in kind of concerned about my
life because i don't want to be
misidentified with these morons throwing
rocks at people with guns absolutely no
but i think the important point here is
that i'm trying to make is there's two
things one i think it's fair to say
you've you i i can't speak for you but
i've been on the ground i absolutely
fear the riders more than i would fear
militia members militia members tend to
have firearms training they tend to mean
more skittish about using force or
weapons and this is true of the left
militias as well
when i see when i would see the armed
socialist groups like the socialist
rifle association or whatever they call
themselves
i would feel safer around them as well
because they take it very very seriously
but that being said
when you testified you did have some
concerns about both sides
right he has the nerve to call you
biased but then accuse you of fearing
both the riders and the armed gunmen i'm
like how can the how can the lawyer come
to you and say
the prosecutor i'm sorry you're biased
against those people
and you are also scared about the guys
with guns it's like so which is it who's
he biased against if he's got concern
for safety across the board it sounds
like he's mostly concerned
for himself and not who's doing what but
that's it you film the riders rioting
and say they're writers he literally
called you biased for saying they were
writers he said your footage seems
slanted towards the rioters and i
responded and said yeah because they're
rioting in the footage absolutely like
it just it doesn't make any sense and
that's why i'm watching the tron i'm
like dude you you're what he's doing is
he's insulting the intellect and the
judgment ability of the jurors
because you see this
you know you see this back and forth
where
i'll use myself as an example today he
literally praised me for being a veteran
reporter trying to add credibility to me
when it fit his little narrative and
then at the end
they literally try to discredit me again
at the end of their closing argument
that just that just to me if i was a
juror that would insult me completely
like so so you think i'm that dumb that
i even pick up on it he did it on
multiple occasions one of the biggest
ones was him describing the activities
of rosenbaum and acted like it wasn't a
big deal yeah when he went over
everything that he pulled up in a second
i don't know if he could play that
including the end
isn't that funny though isn't it it's
like listen he he's like oh he uses the
n-word
i want to play this video in a second i
want to play the video yeah it's well
we'll get to it we'll get to it
you want did you want to point out no no
that he contradicted himself when he was
questioning you uh you know drew and
then with his closing arguments he
literally said the opposite of what he
was saying to you so that's that's a
major point here thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time
you